hey guys i'm philip molina and this is a
breakdown for the Walking Dead Season
six Episode nine no way out and oh my
god
this was I I don't even want to say how
arguably just maybe the best episode of
the show ever
or at least way freaking up there
definitely is on IMDb way up there we
got that extremely explosive opening
scene there was an entire family that
was like shredded in seconds the really
like emotional team-up that happened
near the end of help slaughter all those
walkers and obviously the freakin shot
heard round the world
and if you who read the comics you know
I mean obviously this was a huge deal
that you've been waiting for this whole
time I know I have but also you know
after this moment everything changes
everything for Rick Alexandria Karl
obviously it all is about to just go in
a whole different direction I'm so
excited but mostly right here in this
moment I'm really happy with the show I
feel like they totally lived up to it at
least for me I don't know if you guys
agree but obviously it was even if you
don't read the comics a huge climactic
game-changer there's clearly a lot to
talk about I'm very excited about it so
let's just jump right into the opening
images we return to that scene that was
at the end of last episode where Daryl
Sasha and Abraham are headed back to
Alexandria and they get stopped by these
out of nowhere badass guys if you're
like what do you mean the scene from the
end of last episode it's cuz this was
one of those weird scenes that they like
removed and put in the middle of into
the Badlands and you had to watch that
show just to get this scene so if you're
seeing it for the first time in this
episode you missed a lot of it we saw it
again a different time something that
they did here so that we didn't have to
watch it identically was they kind of
chopped it up and it was fade to black a
couple of times kind of cool I don't
think that they were like purposely
going for anything there but to me it
did kind of remind me of like turning
the page on a comic you're just kind of
are in and out of the story for sex and
the only reason I mentioned that is
because this episode was so out of the
comics that I was interesting that it
kind of felt that way but I don't think
that was on purpose
what was on purpose is starting the
whole thing with a freaking huge
explosion
and getting this really excited for this
episode now before I go all into that
boom-boom moment I want to catch this up
actually because it feels like it's been
months since we've seen these people and
it kind of has but in their timeline
it's only been a few days so let's recap
really quick what's happened to Daryl
Sasha and Abraham they were the ones
that were leading the Horde away by the
car that's where we kind of roughly
started with them this season they kind
of get separated Abraham goes off and
almost killed himself but he gets a
rocket-launcher out of it Daryl meets
some people that are probably on the run
from the game that we just met I think
they're Dwight and Sherri he loses his
crossbow and his motorcycle they steal
it there was also a bunch of weird like
flirtation between Sasha and Abraham all
of that happened in these last few days
most recently Daryl finds a fuel truck
meets up with his team again and now
we're back here that all just happened
over the last few days it's been a
really crazy couple of days for
everybody we'll get everybody else after
this moment but back to here these bad
guys who are bad news they ordered Daryl
Sasha and Abraham to come out and hand
over their guns and obviously that
really pisses Daryl off because he just
lost his crossbow like a few hours ago
then this unnamed gang lays this on her
your property now belongs to negan no I
did kind of talk about negan on that
last episode but it's worth repeating
this is the best villain from The
Walking Dead comic Bar None and I
actually don't even want to say too much
about him because I'm sure the show is
gonna introduce him in his own very cool
way just know the negan storyline the
most intense best dramatic story line in
the entire comic series I'm so pumped
for it if you're like oh don't leave me
hanging there there are some clues to
what negan is like from this scene and
these guys our first clue of what
negan's like notice how surprisingly
smart these people are despite how they
look they can very quickly tell how
resourceful our group is because of the
tanker truck if you can get your hands
on a tanker your people our person wants
to know they size up Abraham very
quickly they know they have more stuff
these people are surprisingly perceptive
to despite how much they might want to
murder you
you're like weirdly polite as if that
makes it better that they want to kill
you they say
thank you and please thank you three
they have this very brutal code clearly
that they live by if you have to eat
that's not to nibble bite chew
swallow repeat and it's just obvious
that things to them are very simple and
straightforward as long as you live by
their code for their weirdly obsessed
with the idea of property their own
property are their people's property
there's more there is always who things
belong to we actually saw a little bit
of that in that other episode with the
guys watch that they take off of the
severed arm because again you can't let
go of property it's very important to
negan and his people v they're very
organized if these are the guys that
Dwight and Chery running from and I'm
pretty sure they are but also they're
not even the same ones that they were
running from in that episode you've got
to remember that Dwight told Darrel he
had been with them since the beginning
and he didn't even know everyone that
was in that group so it's clear this is
at least a small part of something that
might be closer to a freaking army and
that just shows like they're freaking
legit six and this is the last thing
that I want you to pull from this group
as to what negan is like they're
freaking evil I just straight-up
they are just beyond morals at this
point we introduced ourselves by just
popping one on you right off the bat
they have a freaking policy to kill
someone in every group they meet
immediately just to prove some sort of
point this guy's even just toying with
them about their own lives saying he's
gonna kill Abraham and Sasha saying he's
not gonna kill them saying he is gonna
kill them it's they're just bad people
but then BOOM
amazing like just way too freakin kicked
this whole episode off with a bang Daryl
has found an even more lethal
replacement than his crossbow
Abraham's rocket launcher which I'm sure
Abraham probably wants back at some
point he blows all Megan's gang up well
at least this part of it I am whatever
you can tell I was kind of shocked it
was exactly what we all wanted to happen
but they actually did it so my reaction
was a lot like Sasha's reaction
yep also if you look really closely
actually right before the explosion if
we go back there's a car pulling into
frame way in the background I don't know
that that's on purpose there's a chance
it was just a mistake on the production
but I prefer to instead believe because
it's much cooler to believe this that
might have been negan just watching this
whole thing or part of negan's gang
either way makes sense that when you see
a freaking rocket launcher blow your
friends up
you don't run toward that you run away
from that for a moment but it also makes
sense that they'll be back with
reinforcements I'm so pumped and kind of
scared for our friends then we get a
shot of this guy's severed burning
melting face head kinda sad actually
that we never learned his name cuz he
was surprisingly a pretty cool
interesting character that's that again
he's insignificant compared to what's
gonna come but also note how Abraham
here he gets a great line nibbling on
their nipple on that you burn face and
that's just one of his great lines he
gets another one later but also just in
general dis burned face thing that's
another reference to negan a very
obvious one that they're making but I
don't actually want to bring it up just
yet because it's a cool reveal let's
just say don't forget this image as if
you could because it's freaking the
things of nightmares so I just hold on
to that in your little memory and then
we'll bring it back up when it comes
full circle later moving on our other
opening images are here in Alexandria
which is now just totally swarming with
walkers ever since
yeah that and if you think about that
scene with negan's gang it's kind of
like a pre credits cold-open
so I kind of feel like this is the real
start of this episode and I feel like
that's why there's a little image here
that they wanted us to hold on to we
have all of these walkers surrounding us
it's setting that feeling of there's no
way out it's almost claustrophobic this
whole episode is very claustrophobic
actually but then there's that sign come
in we're open it's kind of a pretty
obvious joke where it's like yeah the
walls are down we are now open to
threats and you're seeing that with all
these hundreds of walkers come in but
there's actually another meaning that I
want to touch on later once we have a
little bit more context I'll come back
to that at the end moving on
note these shots of these walkers
they're all from a low camera angle and
that's foreshadowing something here the
walkers block our view from everything
they're all around us they're towering
over us it's claustrophobic again no way
out but also it's the perspective you
would have if you were a little kid like
Sam so the way Sam sees the walkers we
all know will play a huge role in the
events of this episode and I think this
moment is just setting that up in
advance then there's just like bleak
music plays as we see the grossest like
red rover line that you've ever seen as
you sneak through the horde and notice
how we're not even hearing moans and
growls from the walkers despite how many
there are which normally we do hear that
I think they're just making everything
eerily quiet in this moment and I know a
lot of us saw in the last episode when
it was ending with Sam's little that we
thought everything was gonna break and
just go to hell right then and that's
actually how it happens in the comics it
very quickly turns around but the show
keeps everything under control for the
moment and I actually I'm sorry I love
that they stretched this moment out
normally that's a big annoying thing
that you know when it takes a really
long time on the show to do something I
was very quick in the comics this is the
exception for me this moment so much is
about to happen it was worth just making
me squirm and I bet you guys were
squirming too I just really feel the
weight of this moment for how crazy
things are about to be also note how
there's a little bit more foreshadowing
when you see Sam stare at that one
Walker with his guts hanging out and he
just like starts to lose it like you can
tell he's going to break eventually
funny enough this is gonna sound forced
but I actually very recently did a prank
for break calm where we showed
eyes guts burst out too like real
unsuspecting people and yeah I learned
that messes people up like it breaks
their minds go watch that if you want
after this video and you'll see like
that's just the kind of thing for some
reason when you see a person that looks
roughly like a person but their guts are
hanging out that just messes you up and
you can see it's a mess in Sam up here
you can also see this messing up real
people's minds in that other video if
you want to watch it anyway moving on oh
actually before we fully move on it's
worth remembering this breaks people to
see creepy walkers like this it broke
already forgot his name the guy who
blows his brains out when he saw it and
Sam again a small child who has never
seen walkers up close before
and this is the first moment here and
they're like everywhere all around them
in their guts are hanging out don't hate
Sam anymore that kid just saw poor guy
now moving on
Rick changes his mind about going to the
armory and decides they'll go back to
the quarry and they'll get their cars to
help move the walkers again or something
more important I think this is a good
moment to just remember how crazy
everything's been going for this group
again everything we've seen in season
six has taken place mostly in just two
awful days so for them it started with
the quarry that was full of walkers and
then it all kind of comes undone early
so they have to quickly execute this
plan where they send the walkers away
but then at the same time the Wolves
attack Alexandria and then the horn is
blaring and then the wall falls and the
walkers take over and also Carl and Ron
had their boy fight and Deanna's died
and all of this crazy stuff has just
happened last like 48 hours crazy
something else worth pointing out here
if you remember very recently Gabriel
and Rick world not on good terms I'd
like to help us well know who else
Rick was basically bullying Gabriel his
stupid fly trips and pulling him down
but it is nice to see Gabriel kind of
get back on Rick's good side by offering
to take Judah to the church to keep her
safe by the way this is what was
interesting to me I remember the last
episode I was like uh how are they gonna
bring Judith through this thing it's a
very different situation in the comics
so I was like are they gonna kill a baby
so no they didn't kill a baby Judith you
survive another day as long as you shut
the hell up and hide under some zombie
guts you last also she's like the most
adorable baby now so it's gonna be a
pretty hard thing to kill also I
I guess you can kind of hate Sam just a
little bit here cuz dude you should have
listened to your mom like you'll you
know you're not tough I'm sorry but if
you're your well now you're nothing
you're your mud and guts but weirdly
despite the episode name you had a way
out sorry
then we got to catch up with this whole
group that we forgot about Rosita and
Tara and Alanna Masterson holding out
that a hoodie as far as she can to cover
her pregnant belly and it's alright
after Carole and Morgan have knocked
each other out because they were mad at
each other and they're both kind of dumb
and wrong in the situation about the
alpha wolf but anyway Carole doesn't
waste any time because dr. Denise was
taking his hostage by the guy she's like
so eager to be basically told you so but
Oh Carole even though I'm goes very mad
at Morgan for keeping this guy in
general you've got a lot of blame on
your shoulders too
here's the thing with Carole she doesn't
get a ton of screen time in these couple
of episodes but she's kind of the key to
a lot of the things that are going on
and her debate and fighting with Morgan
over the Wolfman that is kind of at its
core about the same thing that the
Walking Dead overall as a show is about
they're exploring the same themes
injustice moments that's why Carole's
actions are really important here but
these ideas of do you have to kill
someone when they're bad or can people
change and become good again in this
world do you need to become bad in order
to survive in this world these are
things that are just at the center of
Walking Dead and even though Rick is
usually the one that's talking about
this stuff and these people will never
survive unless they do this Carol is the
one that embodies that the most and keep
in mind Carol is the whole reason why
Sam has his panic attack later but the
reason she scared him so much in that
past episode I'm sure you remember this
play you'll be outside the bones
tied to a tree and they will tear you
apart and eat you up all your stuff
alive so that the whole reason she did
that is cuz Sam caught her stealing guns
so that was her breaking her character
of Suzie homemaker and had she accepted
that maybe Alexandra could be a great
place maybe it would be what they're all
dreaming for well rick has been telling
them they were gonna find if she had
believed that she never would have told
Sam that think she would have just lived
there and been happy I don't mean that
that would have been better for the show
or better for the plot or better for
anything but if she had believed that
she would have never had to scare Sam
and do all that but instead because she
believes that no it's impossible to find
an idyllic town it's impossible to live
in this dream world that own belief kind
of caused that to break down for Sam
that entire family and rip his dream
world collapses because Carol didn't
even believe in it in the first place
also I don't know that the wolf man
would have escaped I don't know if these
events would have gone down the same way
if carol hadn't done her part remember
I'm still mad at Morgan too but my point
is Carol you've got a lot of blame on
your shoulders too and here's my concern
about this she's just gone through a
very large arc and we see uh maybe the
actions that she's taken maybe they're
not justified maybe in order to survive
in this world you need to have a little
bit of hope you see Rick finds that at
the end I haven't seen Carol find that
hope yet and that kind of worries me
about her survivability as a character
if she just gone through a whole arc and
they really want to prove a point about
what that means
I don't know Carol I will say is not
safe in the comics so is she safe here I
don't know that said Carol if you're
watching this which you you are not
because you're a fictional character but
if you could watch this
you should know it's not too late you
can change Rick just changed you don't
have to act all suicidal you can become
a person that can survive in the new
world that Rick is gonna make but again
you're a fictional character so you're
not watching this so good luck to you
next up are two scenes that they kind of
intercut constantly back and forth
there's Glenn and Enid in the church
looking for supplies to rescue me
and there's also the alpha wolf who's
trying to escape with Denis as his
hostage these two scenes are definitely
kind of parallel but inverted from each
other and together they're kind of
outlining a core theme of this episode
so let's look at each scene individually
in the church Glenn is basically playing
the role of Enid's guardian angel I mean
he's literally preaching like a preacher
to her from a pulpit to help her
understand a Bible quote so one on the
wall face without works is dead so
that's from the Epistle of James in the
New Testament of the Bible and it's
focused on the idea of patient
perseverance during trials and
temptations that's what's needed in
order to be alive not defeating the
temptations but the work you do while
you're trying to persevere that's life
not perseverance itself so you got to
compare that to Enid's mantra that she
always repeats herself just survive
somehow that's left her not only
spiritually lost but kind of hollow
inside just survives somehow there's no
connection there to anything or anyone
else and Glenn and that Bible verse are
kind of saying otherwise the only true
salvation is by doing good works
probably for other people besides
yourself putting your faith in those
people and it's their love that make you
who you are that make you alive anything
else is dead people you look
they made you who you are it's a lot
like Schrodinger's cat actually that
idea that if there's a cat in a box and
you can't see it you can't hear it is it
alive you don't know it's not connected
to anything else inside of that box
it's basically might as well be dead
right that's enid right now if she
doesn't connect to anything then is she
really alive not really then kind of
like a fancy funeral within a church you
got the stained-glass cross behind him
and Glenn basically gives a eulogy for
his dead friends and there's two things
that are interesting to me here one
Glenn you mentioned Andrea but not tdawg
and your sister-in-law Beth come on
Glenn don't look out 40 dogs
see dog ha - Glenn seems very
christ-like lately he's here framed by
the cross he's preaching Christ's
message about loving your neighbor
caring for others more than you care for
yourself and Perri now with this very
recent death and resurrection feels like
this season the Bible imagery that's
surrounding Glenn I think it's all
carrying some sort of greater symbolic
meaning that we're gonna learn more
about as the season progresses but I
definitely think they're doing this on
purpose parallels to the Christ
storyline it's definitely in there it is
an election year maybe the walking dead
show runners are trying to run for
president and appeal to Christians but
they're definitely making some sort of
connection here I'm wondering how that's
gonna turn out for Glenn considering how
it turned out for Christ okay now let's
check out the religious flipside of that
heavenly scene with the demonic wolf man
who is basically the devil on Denise's
shoulder he's using the same kind of
argument that Glenn does Hugh cuz you're
still here and he's telling Denise that
she can also change except he wants her
to change kind of basically for the bad
to care about herself and embrace their
style of living and it's really
interesting to pay attention to how that
goes for these two couples because in
enid storyline where she embraced the
christ-like figure and cares for others
they make it and in the devil storyline
with Denise that doesn't go as well in
fact it's not until she rejects his idea
of caring for yourself and wants to help
him and then eventually help others that
Denise gets away and survives the whole
thing
you get me to the infirmary I save your
life and this also comes back to Carol
and Sam look what happens when people in
this timeline now care about themselves
first she has really hurt this kid and
ruined his life too so that thinking of
just being aggressively about your own
needs it doesn't work anymore it turns
out and that's another reason why the
show is gonna take a big turn now quick
fun little reference when they're
looking for a hollowed-out Bible that
could have stuff they need in it and
they find that stuff it might be a
reference to the Shawshank Redemption
it's a little pickaxe inside of that
movie that they find salvation within
but the reason why I think this might be
on purpose that movie was directed by
Frank Darabont the first showrunner for
the walking dead okay moving on and okay
it's finally night remember very very
long days right now and rick is leading
the line through alexandria still
wielding his bloody axe which i love
seeing him carry because that's his
go-to weapon in the comics and he is
such a badass with it and i want to see
them have him use that forever on the
show a lot more at least
but yeah it's night time now and that's
leading to just this basically the most
gut-wrenching i'm not intending that pun
by the way just horrifying scene that i
think this show has ever done it starts
with these terrifying shots from Sam's
point of view these close-ups on these
walkers and their broken teeth and their
chewing and spitting up blood again
remember Sam has never seen anything
like this in his life and I only pick on
Carol one more time just right here
again she has traumatized him just like
the Wolfman has traumatized Denis a bit
and when he tried to scare her she kind
of freezes up for a bit the same thing
is happening here and I'm gonna remind
you that Carol not long ago was
pretending to be a wolf person she even
had to W on her head and I feel like
that was closer to what she's really
like then she's been this whole season
pretending to be a wolf II then
leave him no but now like I said earlier
we get the consequences of that way of
thinking so each of these shots is very
surreal and nightmare-like and that's
something in the walking dead actually
never really does they try to always
give you a perspective from the point of
reality to the point where it's actually
sometimes very slow or simple and that
makes it feel more real this it's shot
like a horror movie it actually reminded
me of some of the really stylized shots
in Michael Jackson's Thriller video and
that was based on really classic old
Hollywood horror movies from like the
40s and 50s so this scene has a lot of
shots on it that you don't normally see
and I think it's trying to really
heighten how much of a horror and
nightmare it is inside of Sam's brain
like from his mind he's living in a
horror movie right now
and that's something that we've gotten
so used to on The Walking Dead's that
they had to shoot it this new way to
kind of show this is what it's like to
someone who's never seen zombies before
or walkers in their world and we see
that really disturbing shot of a walker
child in pajamas walking away from them
note how we don't even see the kids face
it's so that Sam can see that and be
like oh that's basically me my
nightmares have come true I used to see
walkers in my imagination now not only
am I here around them I'm amongst them
I've become one of them of course that
freezes them that breaks him beyond
repair at that point people try to
whisper him to save him but it's
obviously too late and he freaks out and
he dies one of the most gruesome deaths
you can give a little kid if he's
screaming in agony and his mom and his
brother are watching
and God you can even hear a baby crying
and it's almost like that that might not
even be Judith it almost feels like just
a representation of that idea of a mom
losing her infant her baby in in Sam and
it's just heartbreaking and then it gets
worse Jesse obviously just totally loses
it and she won't let go of Sam and then
the walkers take her to which actually
just hits Rick so hard he's been
building this relationship with her for
like two seasons now when he was gonna
kill her husband because he was beating
her and then he does end up killing her
husband and a lot of people myself kind
of included thought maybe Jesse will
fill in for the role that Andrea plays
in the comics where this will be his
love interest and the new relationship
that we can root for and it'll last a
long time and no it doesn't happen in
fact even the actress was like maybe
they'll keep me alive she sent an email
to Scott Gimple The Walking Dead
showrunner and she was basically like
how about we don't kill Jesse she
suggested that Jesse just runs off
because she's in so much grief and then
maybe in like two seasons they find her
and she's like just a crazy lady now and
he was like no yeah we're gonna kill you
just like in the comics in fact this all
plays out very very close to the exact
frames from the comics so you can see
and actually until that moment where
Rick chops off her hand which is also aw
God just so incredibly crazy I want you
to notice all before this rip was
totally frozen just seeing those flashes
before he finally takes action to chop
her hand off but I'm gonna come back to
that in a second about Rick right there
in that moment freezing up and what it
means for him later and then as if we
needed to get worse it gets worse
Ron picks up Karl's gun and he pointed
out Rick and blind rage saying clearly
he holds Rick responsible for killing
now his entire family and I bet Rick
regrets teaching Ron how to shoot
recently but then boom Michonne with the
save before he can kill Rick I just
impaling Ron with her sword and I want
to point out two things here about this
whole ron situation one it's kind of
funny that very recently karl was
calling Ron's dad an
my dad killed your dad but you need to
know something
your dad was an and now Ron's
like okay cool
your dad killed my whole family so I'm
going to kill him kind of imbalance
response to him going is that an
but to Ron gets that shot off and we see
where it lands right here and if you
think I never come back to stuff that I
say I'm gonna come back to eventually
I'm gonna come back to something that I
set up once before in a previous episode
breakdown I pointed out how Ron kept
closing his right eye as he was taking
aim even though that's not a good way to
aim and I feel like right there they
were trying to hint at it a little bit
the foreshadowing Ron basically looking
at Carl closing his right eye repeatedly
saying yeah I'm gonna take your right
eye but then yeah this the craziest
moment of maybe the whole show ever
Carl basically mirroring what poor
little Sam was saying last episode just
as scared just as confused about what
just happened and oh my god what a
freakin gruesome wound it's insane to
think that they were able to pull this
off Greg Nicotero talked about how they
were able to do this and stave really
true to the image in the comics in the
comics most of his head is frickin gone
and there's no way you'd survive that
but in the episode they got really close
in a way that's still realistic
so let's actually dive into this moment
a little bit more because it's the
craziest thing the show's ever had the
few changes they end up making to this
moment we're only because Greg Nicotero
one of the show's executive producers I
believe that there's no way they could
do exactly what they did in the comics
without people thinking that he was
definitely dead so they created a very
realistic version of the same thing and
they use this amazingly realistic
mannequin that is meant to look like
Chandler Riggs the actor that plays
coral and the wound on it is meant to
look like it maybe bounced down the
bullet did hits corals cheek bone and
then goes outward and maybe those bone
fragments kind of went into his eye and
then they digitally kind of cut that out
from the mannequin and put it onto
Chandler Riggs actual face it's exactly
the same thing they did in Breaking Bad
quick spoiler here for Breaking Bad it
only lasts a second that image of
Gustavo Fring the same special effects
team did that and did this and the
moments where Ric is carrying coral
that's all the mannequin you can see how
realistic it looks it's pretty
crazy but the thing I also want to point
out just about this moment here is this
is one of the most iconic moments in The
Walking Dead comics - just this specific
frame and I've one I'm really glad the
show
I think totally pulled it off in a
realistic gruesome way but - it's
important to remember the reason you
take out someone's eye and eyes these
things that control our perspective
they're purposely doing this and they've
even talked about this a little bit
about how moving forward this character
Carl will literally have a completely
different perspective on the world a
different view on it and that's just
another way to signify what is happening
in the show in this exact episode at
this exact moment everything is gonna be
now seen in a new way
Rick is completely changing his
worldview Carl is gonna completely
change his worldview literally and
figuratively and honestly it doesn't
exactly seem like they're gonna change
them into the same views so we're
setting up a lot of drama here and just
blowing out so much eyes pretty freakin
intense so it's both literally really
interesting and figuratively pretty
interesting - moving on to another quick
check-in with Eugene and Rosita where
Eugene is finally starting to sum up
some courage here ID says sooner or
later we're fighting our way out
obviously that's another reference to
the episode title of no way out our
characters are backed into a corner like
a cat they have to fight their way out
it's the only way that they'll survive
this and it's actually in contrast to
every time they've ever had a home
before they take off they run they let
that old place blow up the honest
trailer recently kind of nails that
moment one story of the group finding a
safe haven that eventually gets
destroyed again and again and again and
again but this time they can't run so
they got to fight their way out all
right we'll come back to this moment
later though but keep going Jesse
screaming and Ron shooting attracts a
bunch of walkers away from Denise and
the wolf man I kind of talked about what
was going on between them earlier but
now I'll just focus on the fact that the
wolf man does maybe change for a second
we see that he could keep going but
instead he goes back and saves Denise
and no it should not work out for him we
gotta ask why is he doing that
is it because he needs her as a doctor
figure he needs a medical attention is
it because he's changed and he's finally
thinking about others and some stuff has
sunk in
and finally like what Morgan's been
trying to teach him is because he has a
Hotspur Denis we don't know why and you
can tell he actually doesn't even know
why won't you tell me why you think he
did it in the comment aside from that of
course note who takes them out none
other than Carol
someone who abides by his mentality and
again it's not a road to survivability
anymore definitely not for him and again
that makes me wonder is it gonna be a
road for survival for Carol still I
don't know I will say that that last
moment of wolfman his dying breath he
pushes a walker out of Denise's way that
touches right there on that thing can
people be redeemed can a bad person turn
good it's that whole concept of oh we
should put him down it's only way to
keep us safe and yet did he change right
there again it's a whole theme of The
Walking Dead in general who do we need
to become to survive and can you be too
far gone to say then I love this scene
that we get from Denis where she turns
into this like badass ER doctor as Rick
is running up with Carl and know when
Aaron asked if Carl was bit Denis
doesn't even look she's just like nope
why do you think she does that my guess
and this is just a guess is that Denis
in this moment knows the power of
positivity and hope right now Spencer
Aaron Heath they're all just clearly
freaked out and someone needs to be
inspiring hopefulness and courage
instead of that despair and fear that
Carol had Dundas and that the wolf Anne
was trying to teach her this is one of
these turns of just jumping into
positivity and hope and I think this is
a spark that is about to ignite a lot of
positivity and hope and a lot of people
in the rest of the episode but we'll get
to that first up Rick talked about a
spark setting who off remember how I was
saying earlier that Rick was frozen in
those moments where he just literally
just didn't know what to do when
everyone was dying everything was
falling apart around him all of that
energy that fear that anger that rage it
all finally hits him almost a good
delayed reaction and Rick goes out to do
what apparently he does best and that's
kill some freaking walkers in this
moment we're seeing Rick on leash he's
like a freakin superhero for so long
he's had to worry about is everybody
else safe but in this moment Carl he
can't do anything for there's no one
else that he actually really care
is that much about so he just goes out
there all alone to let all of that rage
out and if you notice the editing is
really clear about what's going on here
we start with that one long take to give
us a scope of the danger but then it's
followed by all these really quick cuts
to highlight rick is the savage one he's
on the offensive now you almost feel bad
for the walkers welcome you sick Rick on
that
he's now finally taking charge in a
freaking gruesome way and that image of
him all alone out there fighting against
definitely overwhelming odds
if Denise's positivity a second ago was
the spark that would inspire people this
is the equivalent of the bazooka into a
lake of gasoline where everyone gets
totally inspired by this Michonne's out
there first and Heath and air and
Spencer and then random Alexandrian and
they don't they're secondary characters
they could die at any moments they don't
know that of course but everyone goes
out there to try to save the day
and then we even see Gabriel in the
church have his first actual badass
moment we've been praying praying that
God will save our town our prayers have
been answered God will save Alexandria
because God has given us the courage to
save it ourselves
Gabriel is basically saying that faith
alone that's not gonna save them they
have to fight to save themselves fight
their way out and another way to put it
would be faith without works is dead
remember some of those first words he
said to Rick when they saved him at the
very beginning of the Gabriel story I
called for help okay you just sat there
waiting cowardly honestly and putting
too much faith in God to save him
and now instead of what he did before
which was hide inside of a church while
parishioners were dying outside now he's
the one that leaves the church taking
matters into his own hands getting a
little blood on his collar
finally and joining the fight and he's
followed by everybody else Rosita
Carolyn Morgan put aside their
differences Eugene who's another coward
honestly grows a pair and he gives us
what I think is a nice best line no one
gets the clock out today and hail
this is a story people are gonna tale
the reason I really like that line is
that it's just so damn confident and its
really forward-thinking of Eugene it's
implying that not only are they gonna
win the night but that Alexandria is
gonna grow it's gonna become a larger
society and then eventually civilization
is gonna happen again and that may be in
future generations in history classes
they're gonna talk about this night and
Eugene himself might be in those history
books and that is just such a cool
thought and moment to have yourself I'm
sure it's exactly how George Washington
felt when he beat the zombies back to
gain our independence
moving on Morgan then finds the wolf man
now turned as a walker and he tells him
he's sorry before putting him down
clearly he regrets that he wasn't able
to rehabilitate him though he doesn't
know that maybe he did when he tried to
help safe beneath but it's also a
reference to very recently when they had
a very similar moment cuz when he first
knocked him out earlier this season then
Glenn and Enid rushed to help save
Maggie and oh my god whoo I'm sure you
guys were also like are they about to
actually kill Glenn is Glenn finally
gonna die like that moment was
terrifying where Glenn is is just backed
up against the wall there and honestly
they could have gotten away with killing
him there because maybe the whole reason
that he was resurrected was so he could
come back here and save his wife and
future child and it would kind of
resemble Christ being resurrected only
to go into heaven again and they didn't
do it and it was a very cool way they
saved him I loved this moment
appreciate it pal and oh my god that was
like such a relief moment and Abraham's
line made me smile so stupid Felipe like
just really loved that moment but enough
with destroying Glen or making a
syncline is gonna die we just it's we're
just too sensitive right now and we just
need it sometime there's a lot of chaos
that's gonna come in the future so I
know it's gonna get bad again but just
for a little while can it just be like
somebody else's turn at bat appreciate
it Wow Darrell den plots to corral all
the walkers into one place and he dumps
the fuel from the truck into the pond
and torches it with his obviously new
favorite weapon which is kind of an
upgrade from a crossbow his freaking
rocket launcher now which again used to
be Abraham's rocket launcher so we'll
see how that goes but I want to point
out he just learned this trick from
Sheri when she described in a previous
episode that they got a bunch of walkers
to go in one place when they set that
terrible forest fire it's just fires
burning them all away and the other ones
in town they were drawn to it they just
walked right into the flames this is a
newly acquired trick and daryl is
thinking very quickly but also note how
the walkers are drawn to the flames like
they're descending back into hell as
demons who have just been defeated would
it's not only just another biblical
reference it's also really freaking cool
looking and that's because that fire was
not CGI that was a real fire and those
people that will have walkers that were
descending into it those were real
people just wearing all kinds of flame
retardant clothing I think it was
honestly totally worth it even though
there were real people's houses nearby
that could have been burned down sorry
it was worth this moment just looking
very cool very memorable and also way
better than the CGI balloons we saw kind
of recently so a plus for the practical
fire but a triple plus for this montage
here where Rick and the rest of the gang
finish off all of these walkers and I
think it was something like over a
hundred and seventy seven walkers go
down I think Rick is responsible for
killing like 40 or more on his own
eventually we don't even see the walkers
in this montage we just see the people
swinging and
tonight right at the camera it's the
show making a really bold statement
we're at a turning point in this series
it's not about the walkers anymore and
smashing their heads and their brains
going everywhere it's a show about these
people trying to team up work together
to build a society now in the apocalypse
can they make a new world it's only
these faces that matter now and it's one
way to rejuvenate a show that is in its
sixth season and it's kind of why I get
that some people will say this show
might go on forever it's totally
reinventing itself from this point
forward again you read the comics you
know what I mean but if you haven't
trust me everything changes from here on
out then the next morning I think it's
shot a lot like how they shoot a
battlefield in a war movie after the war
battle is done the smoke is rising
there's corpses everywhere you look and
the Alexandrian somehow I've pulled
through United as one covered in the
blood of their enemy and from the look
of it they kind of seemed like didn't
even really lose anybody
it's except for one entire family but
aside from that entire family they look
like war soldiers now they're clinging
to their weapons still and they're just
staring kind of messed up in the head
probably in shell shock but banded
together for sure and so this final
scene really just puts it all very
clearly where rick is tearfully
describing to basically comatose Karl
what his new vision is for this world
Season six has been all about Rick
learning to trust our legs and Rian's
and learning to dream for a brighter
future on her deathbed Deanna told Rick
truck and finally after seeing everybody
come together to accomplish the
impossible and facing the reality of
potentially losing Karl Rick has finally
understood the concept of building a new
world is not only possible but it's
necessary it's all possible I see that
now and he wants Karl to be able to see
it kind of see it sorry by the way this
is all pointing out exactly how it did
in the comics the staging is basically
the same the lines are the same should
be you
I want to make it reality and I think
that's all because this is just such an
important moment that they wanted to do
it just like they did in the comics
where it was another important moment
the moment Rick realizes he's wrong but
also the showrunners have promised that
moving forward they're actually gonna do
a lot more stuff like how they did in
the comics of course they can't do
everything insane because Darrell's not
even into comics different people are
dead but they're gonna stay true to all
the stuff that's great and this is one
of the really important moments of the
comics I'd expect a lot more
side-by-side exactly the same as comic
moments now could be a good time to
catch up on the comics if you're
thinking about it and if you're
wondering we're in the comics we are
it's the section of the comics called no
way out the episodes title anyway let's
just kind of like circle all this back
up bound and put a bow on it for you
Rick's been on the run for years right
he's always been cutting his losses when
his temporary home gets overrun the farm
the prison Woodbury terminus he always
finds a way out and each time he ran he
pushed himself further and further away
from the life he knew before waking up
in that hospital bed he's been losing
his humanity slowly over time and
Alexandria really cornered him it gave
him no way out meaning he could either
die or fight through it and create a new
way out the new way out is to evolve
from survivors constantly on the run to
a United Society that can defend itself
from external threats and that gives us
that other meaning of that sign in the
opening images come on in we're open
Rick is saying Alexandria now from this
moment forward is open for business and
that's gonna go great until negan shows
up okay I'm gonna fly through my
lingering questions just one how do you
think negan's gonna retaliate for Daryl
killing eight of its men we know that
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is signed on to play
negan and he's gonna be making his
appearance some times a season we just
don't know how he's gonna enter and if
it's anything like the comics it's gonna
get just really ugly for a lot of people
and I'm really nervous for everybody I
don't know that they're gonna kill the
same people they kill in the comics I
think everybody is up for grabs but what
do you think - what does it mean now
that everyone's finally back together we
do haven't been all together in this
season for a long time what's gonna
change I know for one Abraham
is now into Sasha not Rosita that feels
like some dramas about to happen what
else is gonna change now that everybody
got back together we had that moment
where Daryl and Glen looked at each
other and they were kind of like oh you
haven't been here either nah man have
you been here enough so I feel like a
lot of stuff is about to like settle and
we're gonna get very new relationships
going on a lot of stuff is gonna feel
different for the people and their
interpersonal relationships can you
think of any others than the Rosita and
Abraham and Sasha one I bet there's more
and three is Carole gonna die what do
you think I'm very nervous for her I I'm
not gonna say that I've heard that she's
gonna die but it just doesn't feel like
it can be Glenn right now it doesn't
feel like certain other characters would
do it there are some that I want to talk
about because I don't I don't want to
start a rumor that that person's gonna
die but Carole is the one that I just
can't mmm do you think Carole is gonna
survive this season obviously I love
this episode so much but let me know
what you thought about in the comments
or if I missed anything which easily
could have happened because I was just
blown away the whole time even though I
kind of know what's gonna happen it
still was maybe my favorite episode ever
of this show maybe I don't know it was
yours let me know also if you like these
Walking Dead Analysis ones breakdown
videos there are a lot of work to do I
really like doing them though but please
make sure to share them and let other
people know about them as long as people
are watching them and hopefully a lot
more people keep watching them I want to
keep making them also if you're new
around here subscribe we do all kinds of
cool stuff on this channel and follow on
Twitter at new rockstars if you want to
know when new videos are coming out and
what new videos are coming out follow me
at fimo on Twitter if you want to ask me
questions about stuff or just chat
thanks for watching all of this it's
been a lot of fun talking to you one day
hopefully you can join me and we can
talk back to me and it won't be such a
one-sided conversation but until then
bye
you